voilà un tir plutôt réussi pour cette
première journée de découverte une
initiation au golf que cette famille a
choisi de faire ensemble
c'est une façon de découvrir un sport
une activité qu'on connaît pas voilà et
puis motiver des ados à sortir un peu
dehors c'était une bonne une bonne
solution
voilà cette année les découvertes du
golfe sont gratuites
on met les bouchées doubles à marcy pour
séduire de nouveaux adeptes
car le club a perdu 6% de ses licenciés
par rapport à 2020 avec le co vite du
coup il ya la personne sont restés
beaucoup plus 16 heures ou plus -
boujaer ont un peu peur donc forcément
ils ont raison d'en renouveler les
personnes qui étaient plus loin et et
avec les confinements les les
couvre-feux c'était plus compliqué des
horaires plus contraints moins
d'animations sur site ont rebuté
certains joueurs mais la réputation dit
élitiste du golfe serait aussi un frein
à sa pratique pour marseille c'est pas
vrai c'est archi faux parce que vous
pouvez aller sur parking n'y a pas des
voitures de luxe etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle un peu le golf à
la campagne on al'avantage ici d'avoir
1 45 trous sur un parcours de qui fait
100 ha donc c'est beaucoup et c'est pas
du tout eli pis c'est pas rien de
c'est pas très sympa très onéreux le
club reste accessible et il a permis à
de jeunes talents de faire leurs preuves
l'ambiance en fait ici on est tous on se
connaît tous on se dit tous bonjour on
est vraiment c'est vraiment hyper
familial tout ça et puis même les
coaches sont vraiment attentif c'est
super voilà avec le printemps le golf de
marcilly en ville est semble donc avoir
de très beaux jours devant lui